ça faisait un petit moment que je
n'avais pas fait une vidéo pour vous
donner des astuces des tuto pour
utiliser votre smartphone au mieux et je
me suis donc dit pourquoi pas prendre un
petit peu de temps pour vous donner
quelques astuces pour mieux utiliser
votre smartphone suis donc aujourd'hui
vous révéler 9 astuces dont une
globalement est une légende urbaine ne
marche pas mais je voulais quand même
l'évoquer pour couper court à cette
légende mais avant toute chose moment où
je tourne cette vidéo on est toujours en
confinement liés aux copies de 19 et je
vous ai demandé de m'envoyer vos vidéos
pour savoir comment ça se passe chez
vous on va donc se visionner la vidéo du
jour salue monsieur heureux pendant
confinement j'ai la chance moi d'avoir
un bel étang à côté de chez moi
à moins d'un kilomètre et donc du coup
bah je passe pas mal de temps enfin le
temps qui m'est imparti avec ça pour
essayer de choper des petits oiseaux des
choses comme ça je souhaite à mon profil
ment à tout le monde
bon courage à vous merci à toi pour
cette vidéo on va donc se visionner
maintenant les 9 astuces indispensables
pour votre smartphone vous voulez à
cergy votre smartphone sauf que vous le
charger rien ne se passe votre
smartphone ne prend pas la charge
avant toute chose et avant d'incriminer
votre câble a commencé par vérifier un
point bien souvent vous avez des petites
cochonneries qui viennent s'insérer ici
et à force le contact se fait plus avec
votre chargeur la première chose à faire
est la plus simple c'est de prendre ça
vous prenez le kurde en fait très très
attention vous allez très doucement qui
a toujours des petites cochonneries qui
viennent ça sert l intérieur et à force
empêche le contact avec votre câble de
recharge
évidemment votre smartphone ne
surchargent plus vous pouvez donc
maintenant prendre votre smartphone le
grand chai et là il va se charger sans
aucun problème pour le deuxième point
vous avez un prêt avec votre câble qui
est complètement à 10 mai mais qui
néanmoins fonctionner encore en tout cas
pour le moment
ce qu'il faut donc faire parler du
scotch et vous prenez un stylo vous
allez mettre du scotch tourner la partie
qui allie mais pour venir l'isoler alors
vous faites ça plus ou moins bien selon
votre talent mais vous venez en tout cas
le protéger vous pouvez mettre un bout
de boue comme vous voulez vous partez
d'une extrémité de l'autre vous isolez
ça complètement pour vraiment venir
protéger votre câble vous appuyez bien
aux extrémités comme ça vous avez au
moins quatre qu'un peu isolé en si vous
allez venir démonter votre crayon et
vous récupérez leur sort et vous allez
passer tout leur sort en l'agrandissant
légèrement autour de votre câble pour
nous protéger comme ça vous venez
renforcer isoler votre câble vous n'êtes
pas l'utiliser à nouveau si l'objectif
de votre smartphone est sale ce que je
conseille c'est prendre une gomme et
vous venez gommer ici pour enlever les
cochonneries ça évite de mettre des
produits magiques devenir l'endommager
c'est un truc tout bête mais qui peut
vraiment marcher si votre objectif est
sale bien souvent au bout d'un moment on
a plein de micro rayure sur son
smartphone et une astuce qui dit pour
les enlever vous pouvez utiliser du
dentifrice
on va donc prendre
friis et en maître sur l'écran d'un
smartphone on étale un peu partout et on
verra à la fin ça nous a supprimé les
micros rayures oui ou non
et qu'est ce que je vois deux très belle
micro rayures autant dire que le
dentifrice pour venir enlever les micros
rayures sur l'écran d'un smartphone eh
bien ça ne marche pas c'est une légende
urbaine
il ya une autre astuce qui est vraiment
vraiment vraiment cool affaires vous
prenez une bouteille en plastique
ici c'est un bout de bouteilles de coca
vous aviez le bouchon au dessus tout le
reste de la bouteille en dessous vous
couper juste en dessous du bouchon bien
droit vous avez toute la zone galbées
bombay vous venez coupé en dessous et
vous êtes un objet qui fait cette taille
là et vous allez voir cet objet il fait
de la magie vous allez sur youtube et
vous fait cette recherche l'a hologramme
vidéo vous allez avoir une grande liste
on va sélectionner par exemple la
première ça vous sort une vidéo dans un
format un peu particulier et vous allez
voir ce qu'on va faire avec et c'est là
que la magie opère
ça vient vous créez un hologramme vous
poser bien juste au centre votre bonne
bouteille coupé c'est juste incroyable
que vous puissiez faire ça avec votre
smartphone
une autre astuce qui pourrait vraiment
bien vous aider vous avez votre
smartphone vous avez besoin d'ouvrir ici
votre tiroir de cartes sim sauf que vous
n'avez pas sur vous ou vous avez
carrément perdu l'objet pour faire que
vous soyez chez vous au bureau existe
une solution extrêmement simple il
suffit d'utiliser ce petit truc là un
trombone vous prenez vous l'ouvrez vous
venez l'insérer vous appuyez et vous
ouvrez votre tiroir de cartes sim
extrêmement facilement autre astuce qui
est très cool vous avez envie de changer
un peu l'ambiance lorsque vous allumez
votre flash led vous est pas une
ambiance blanche vous voulez une
ambiance un peu plus coloré et bien
c'est extrêmement facile pour ce faire
il vous faut un smartphone du scotch
rien marqueur vous pouvez prendre un
bout de scotch vous venez de mettre au
niveau de votre flash led et ont su avec
votre marqueur vous venez bien dessiné
dessus pour créer la nouvelle ambiance
c'est quand même plus sympa de faire des
effets film d'horreur un peu en rouge
que en blanc comme ça ça marche tout
beaucoup moins bien une autre astuce qui
est souvent bien connu mais c'est
important de le répéter si votre
smartphone n'a pas de certification ip68
ip67 et que malheureusement il rencontre
de l'eau il existe une solution qui
marche très bien et c'est ça alors on
aura beau faire de la pub à taureaux
ailés avec son riz basmati mais vous
mettez votre smartphone dans du riz du
riz qui n'a jamais rencontré de non plus
vous le prenez vous le planquer
complètement dedans vous laisser pendant
plusieurs heures qu'est ce que va faire
le riz il va venir absorber l'humidité
pour le supprimer complètement du
smartphone au bout de quelques heures
vous le prenez vous l'enlevez vous
il aurait allumé et si tout se passe
bien ça devrait fonctionner dernière
astuce et non des moins que vous êtes
chez vous vous souhaitez faire la
cuisine vous souhaitez faire de la
peinture mais vous avez quand même
besoin de votre smartphone pour suivre
des recettes
eh bien il existe deux solutions
principales pour une aire protégée la
première c'est ça ces films fraîcheur
vous prenez votre smartphone vous le
mettez dans le film vous l'entouré bien
vous protéger bien et ensuite vous
enlevez le film vous débrouiller pour
qu'il soit complètement étanche et là
vous pouvez l'utiliser très très
facilement sans prendre absolument aucun
risque pouvaient utiliser tous les
boutons
si vous avez de la pâture sur les mâts
de la farine quoique ce soit votre
smartphone est protégé deuxième match
sinon des mois vous pouvez utiliser ça
ça c'est un sac congélation prenez votre
smartphone vous le glisser à l'intérieur
du sac vous refermez votre sac pour
qu'il soit complètement étanche et vous
pourrez utiliser votre smartphone très
facilement sans risquer de l'endommager
avec de la farine de la peinture ou que
sais-je encore voilà pour ces quelques
astuces dites moi si vous les
connaissiez si ça vous aura aidé si ça
vous intéresse que je refasse des vidéos
pour vous donner des tuteurs des astuces
pour votre smartphone que ce soit aussi
bien convenir le protège et l'utiliser
ou même des astuces pourquoi pas au
niveau logiciel mark et moi tout ça bien
évidemment en bas en commentaire et si
vous avez vous vos propres astuces vous
pouvez le remarquer également en bas en
commentaire sur ce je vous embrasse ou
donnent rendez vous extrêmement
rapidement au quotidien par les faits
que moore des bizots de l'amour a très
vite qu'un cadeau
le
[Musique]
obama